-Welcome back, everybody.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-This is "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all going to
vote on whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
You see them there?
Yeah. Wow. Perfect.
[ Crowd cheering ]
Wow. Very vocal audience.
-Very tweety.
-Yeah. You can vote for
all of them
or you can vote for
none of them.
Whatever you want to do,
I just want you to have fun.
We're going to
see the results live.
We have a very
expensive polling system...
-Ooh!
-...that we spent
millions of dollars.
-Really?
-Yeah.
We won the Mega Millions
last week...
-Are you kidding? Two weeks ago.
-...and spent
all the budget on this
garage-door-remote-control
polling system.
You press green if you like it,
red if you don't love it.
Higgins, Roots,
you all have clickers?
-Ready.
-Alright.
Whichever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out live on
the show right now
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
-Mm!
-It's a shared experience.
Someone just walked out.
Alright,
you guys ready for this?
Here's the first tweet is...
♪♪
-Wow.
-Yeah.
Almost like a stunned silence.
-More like a,
"Oh, I never thought of that."
-Yeah. Hmm.
Alright, I think if --
What do you think it's gonna be?
Tariq, what are you feeling?
50/50?
-Probably 50/50 on that one.
-Yeah, I'm feeling that. Higgs?
-I'm feeling
a little lower than 50/50.
60/40.
-60/40 yes?
-No. 40/60.
I'm saying 40/60.
-Okay.
I'm going to say probably --
I'm gonna say about
50-something votes.
-Oh, I thought
you meant percentages.
-The votes are in.
Let's see the results.
Here we go.
[ Drumroll ]
-Ooh.
-Gosh. Wow.
-Wow!
-Whew! Thank God
I didn't write that one.
You did.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You wrote it.
-I wrote it, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
-I thought it was
a strong observation.
-This next one is...
♪♪
-It's a thinker.
That's an old-school thinker.
-Old school? Yeah.
It's like, come on.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it was like,
"You know how hard my day was?"
-"What's that?"
-"You know my needle I have?"
-"Yeah."
-"Well, I had to go look for it.
You know how hard that was?"
-"Where'd you have to
look for it?"
-"Well, I was doing
my sewing on top of a haystack."
-"What?!"
"That seems awful."
-Let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh, man!
-Oh!
-Almost worse than
the other one.
-Oh, wow!
-Again,
I want to remind everyone,
these don't necessarily
get better.
[ Laughter ]
Let's look at this
next one, here. It goes...
♪♪
-Come on. That's clever.
-I mean, I don't know.
-You don't like this one either.
-Some people are dancing.
Some people are just like,
"No, I'm waiting."
-"I'm done with this."
-Alright, here we go.
Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
Whoa! Whoa! 138.
-That's not bad.
That might be --
So far, that's by far --
-It's more than doubled
the other ones.
-Yeah, it's doubled
the other -- Yeah.
Alright, next up, it says...
-Now they're loosened up. Yep.
♪♪
-Yeah.
-Sliding on the ice.
-I feel good.
-You feel good about this one?
-I feel good about this one.
Tariq, you feel good?
-Yeah, I mean, I think this is
as good as it's gonna get.
-What?
-I think this is as good as
it's going to get.
-Oh.
-We still have one more
after this.
-Yeah, I don't know.
I don't believe in that,
the last one.
-You think this is it.
-I think this is it.
-You think this is
the highest one.
-Yeah. This is the
top of the haystack.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
-I think that
one's gonna be the winner.
It's gonna be the top of
the haystack. Alright.
-I think it doesn't matter
what the next --
-No, don't put
your clicker down!
You're putting
the clicker down?
-Yeah.
-Come on, bud. No, come on.
You got to be in it
to win it, man.
-This is a clicker drop.
-No, they work, they work.
-Okay, okay.
-Alright, this last one.
-This is the last one, right?
-Last one here says...
♪♪
-Come on!
-You got to have faith.
-George Michael said it best,
"You got to have faith."
-Oh, yeah.
You got to risk it
to get the biscuit.
-That's right.
He said that, too.
-I'm going "yes" on this one.
-Yeah, of course
I'm voting "yes" on that.
-I mean, of course.
We've all done that.
At least you
and Higgins and I have.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-For sure.
But, I mean, these guys,
it doesn't seem like
that type of audience.
-Do you think that they're,
like, a very fit audience?
-Yeah, I think they're fit.
I think this audience
wants what they want,
and they're going to get up
and they're going to go
get the remote.
[ Crowd cheering ]
-You're not
running for president.
I mean, come on.
I love the audience
more than you do.
-I think it's
the best audience in the world.
-In the world. No, I said that.
-That's what I think.
[ Crowd cheering ]
-New York City audiences.
-Oh, my gosh.
Let's see -- let's see
the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Oh, no!
That's not the winner.
The winner is number four,
right here.
That is the tweet right there.
[ Dinging ]
I will post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet," and enjoy.